ces derniers temps loana n'en finit plus
de faire la une de l'actualité en cause
une rechute spectaculaire de la jeune
femme a alors qu'elle tournait un
documentaire sur sa vie
un tournage qui a dû être interrompu en
raison d'un black out de loana une
overdose médicamenteuse
hospitalisé en urgence une fois sorti
d'affaires loana nous avait confié que
ces médicaments y auraient été fournies
par sylvie ortega ça a été à la faute de
cause médicaments que j'ai eu ce coma de
plusieurs heures qui aurait pu me coûter
la vie alors que demain documentaire
exclusif sera diffusée sur la nouvelle
vie de loana sur ces 8
la starlette serait à l'heure actuelle
au plus mal une nouvelle descente aux
enfers quelques jours seulement après
une première rechute ce soit nous vous
dévoilons tout sur l'état de santé
actuel de loana
voilà loana donc on a des mots nouvelle
assez inquiétante
guillaume genton alors il paraît qu'elle
n'a pas aimé le documentaire vers m6
story et moi je lui tout à l'heure au
téléphone elle m'a rien dit à ce sujet
là c'est vrai que le documentaire
c'était une enquête dont on a traité
toutes les polémiques dans ce
documentaire avec notamment les périodes
plus sombres de sa vie notamment frais
de copains qui qui était quelqu'un de
très toxique pour elle on l'a traité en
tant que tel dans le documentaire on n'a
pas dit que ce qu'avait fait frais de
copains c'était bien bien au contraire
c'est extrêmement grave ce qu'il a fait
il a notamment reconnu justement avoir
été violent avec elle mais c'est
important de le traiter d'un point de
vue journalistique on l'a absolument pas
mis en avant frais de cauvin mais c'est
vrai que ce documentaire il était un peu
plus polémiques sur ses vite demain soir
il y aura un documentaire beaucoup plus
positif autour de noël aille de sa
nouvelle vie et elle est très heureuse
dedans donc je suis un peu étonné
d'entendre ça en fait alors dans le dock
loana s'en est prise donc un trait
commun où il avait dit son ex qui aurait
été violent à plusieurs reprises avec
elle et elle a fait une la fin confie
dans ce concours
oui je veux maintenant être la porte un
peu et tu en as tu veux de les femmes
battues il faut le dire maintenant faut
le dire quand on est frappé il faut le
dire à ses amis
il faut le dire ici s'entendent pas
c'est pas grave il faut il faut le crier
haut et fort il faut pas rester dans son
coin et se faire rabaisser sans le dire
encore oui maintenant je voudrais être
le porte parole de ce genre de deux de
blessures que beaucoup de femmes vivent
au quotidien
alors gilles verdez à noël elle a des
hauts et des bas et c'est vrai que la
nuit de loana a été assez inquiétante et
on s'est appelé tôt ce matin avec
guillaume et ça va mieux mais il y a eu
des soucis c'est cuit alors il ya deux
types de show d'abord la renouer avec
sylvie ortega avec des messages
bienveillants
voilà d'accord en revanche sont devenues
copines wheels et voilà il ya des
messages bienveillants la proximité
s'est refaite en revanche pendant la
nuit
loana allait très mal et il ya eu des
messages je vais pas vous en donner le
contenu exact mais son entourage une
partie de son temps ge a reçu des
messages où elle parlait d'une tentative
de suicide à venir donc tout le monde
s'est mobilisé
elle a dit à une heure
du matin je n'en peux plus j'ai tout
perdu ma famille mon appartement
mes amis je suis là où personne ne peut
me trouver seul fatigué j'ai acheté tout
ce qu'il faut pour dormir à jamais ce
message a beaucoup inquiété ce message a
énormément inquiété et des gens dont
guillaume je lui rends hommage et son
équipe se sont mobilisés elle laissait
entendre que la journée passerait celle
d'aujourd'hui et il ya une phrase qui
nous a vraiment inquiété je m'endormirai
pour toujours je suis seul avec mon
chien je sais où le placer j'ai tout
prévu
donc elle envoyait ça je vous donne pas
l'ensemble des messages évidemment et
c'était un dialogue avec quelqu'un qui
s'est instaurée pour essayer de la
secourir
mais c'est vrai que la nuit a été très
compliqué pour loana les retombées dans
un bas de solitude d'angoise
d'inquiétude est vraiment c'est ses
hauts et ses bas elle a besoin de
soutien mais j'ai trouvé que elle a
trouvé un des interlocuteurs à sa
détresse
il ya des gens qui lui ont répondu et je
vois là j'espère que la mobilisation que
j'ai senti un effectif effective à se
poursuivre parce qu'elle en a besoin
nous devons nous inquiéter quand même
oui les lélés honnêtement la nuit a été
inquiétant je vous dis moi j'ai vu le
doc de gueule hier soir je comprends
très bien qu'elle a dû ressentir et j'ai
une question pour toi parce que entre ce
qu'on voit là sur ces 8 où aller
franchement physiquement à prêter
maquiller bien coiffé skis on avait
comme imaginaire il ya une vraie
différence
alors est ce que c'est un choix de la
production et du tout un choix en fait
j'ai une question que la route pour être
pour être transparents en fait on a fait
d'abord celui drm c'est donc quand on a
retrouvé loana elle était dans un état
très compliqué on doit physiquement
c'était très dur de parce qu'elle
sortait de fall elle était à l'hôpital
juste avant est en fait le fait vraiment
je dis pas ça pour nous mettre en avant
mais le fait de ces documents de faire
ces documentaires avec elle elle est
retournée sur des lieux qui ont marqué
sa vie
elle a revu plein de gens il est en
contact avec des gens physiquement elle
s'est embellie voilà je vais rentrer
dans les détails
et c'est normal loana elle a été
rémunérée pour ce dock et on est nous on
veut l'aider même après les docks mode
ce qu'on veut tous ces cas là la shoah
n'a donc voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
changement et vous verrez demain
quelqu'un dont le doc de s'éviter
vraiment il ya que du positif elle est
vraiment heureuse dans les secteurs du
végétal est une passion d'une manière
générale déjà je veux dire qu'elle n'est
pas seule loana elle avec son ami
nicolas qui est son meilleur ami qui à
cannes elle n'habite plus à paris déjà
pour des raisons cachées dans celle là
parce qu'on est inquiet quant aux nano
évidemment le même la première chose
qu'on a fait ce qu'on l'a appelée on a
appelé son entourage et cetera elle vit
en colocation avec son ami nicolas dans
dans le sud de la france
elle n'est pas seule donc ça c'est très
important d'une manière générale la
problématique de la nasa se résume pas à
un tournage ça se résume pas un coup de
fil voilà c'est plus de 20 ans avec des
hauts et des bas c'est vrai que c'est
très compliqué et je trouve que de
trouver comme ça dans l'instantané pour
faire du buzz des clics et des articles
dire voilà ce que c'est de la faute de
luis de l2 ça de ci de ça c'est un peu
facile et un peu réducteur et c'est très
dur parce que là pour le coup mais je le
prends personnellement nous dire voilà
elle l'a mal pris votre dock dons parce
que les raccourcis c'est parce que j'ai
la phénologie passé c'est que c'est toi
qui le dit mais il ya des sous-entendus
qui sont faits sur ça c'est réducteur de
faire ça et c'est des raccourcis qui
sont très durs pour les personnes
concernées
alors on a toujours été bienveillant
avec elle dès qu'elle a besoin de
quelque chose m'a franchement et je le
dis vraiment si je peux l'aider
après le documentaire on le fera avec
grand plaisir on est là pour elle et
c'est très important de l'aider alors on
a une autre
un autre extrait du documentaire vous
est également revenu sur la fameuse
scène de la piscine c'était il ya 20 ans
déjà on parle de loana à loana on a eu
des mauvaises nouvelles cette nuit sur
nos annales childebert dess vous pouvez
nous le rappeler donc et c'est vrai
qu'elle a eu des idées risque angoisse
idées suicidaires avec des sms à
certains membres de son entourage
qu'elle a repris contact avec eux donc
sievert égard oui donc ça reste quand
même quelqu'un c'est vrai que quand elle
se sent pas bien
elle va vers sidi aussi donc est ce qu
est ce que je le redirai entièrement
raison au moment où ça allait mal ses
tenues elle s'est tournée vers elle se
sont re par les réconcilier de manière
bienveillante
il faut dire que loana s'est souvent je
t'aime et après je ne t'aime plus mais
là les relations ont repris en revanche
c'est vrai que sur le plan personnel
elle a du mal ce qui l'a gêné dans le
dans le documentaire c'est de se voir à
20 ans et de se voir vingt ans après
alors je suis revenu sur la fameuse
scène de la piscine
c'était il ya vingt ans dans love story
benjamin castaldi était l'animateur
regarde on avait de l'alcool alors qu'il
y avait des soirées une fois par semaine
et en fait on était complètement bourré
quoi est on allé dans la piscine
garçons et filles me plaisait je devais
lui plaire il s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé mais non comme on a vu qu'il y
avait la fête dans le loft
on sait jamais dit que c'était nous
qu'on allait filmer oui non à guillaume
ne remet absolument pas en cause qu'ils
égarent ta bienveillance et en
professionnalisme parce que c'est lui le
producteur du don absolument rien mais
moi pardon mais loana elle n'a pas
besoin de soutien elle a besoin de
médecins elle n'a pas besoin d'un
producteur elle a besoin d'un
psychothérapeute et j'ai l'impression
qu'on réalimente en permanence son
jukebox de ses névroses de ces maladies
de ses souffrances et qu'on lui fait
beaucoup plus de mal que ce conte même
si on veut bien faire même si ça on
pense que ça fait du bien la lumière on
pense qu'à la évidemment qu'elle a
besoin d'argent mais je pense qu hydro
et comment elle fait comment en fait je
pense qu'il faut qu'elle soit aidée mais
pas du tout par des gens de télé il faut
qu'elle soit aidée par des médecins par
delmi en fait elle nourrit ses névroses
on voit bien galets elle est
complètement perdue elle est le rebelle
reprend contact avec seal your dégâts on
va dire qu'il ya rien de cohérent elle
était seule pendant des années elle a
pas fait télévision ce qu'elle allait
mieux non mais elle l'a fait quand même
pas mal a fait pas mal de programmes
détaillés dont l'âge de 10 ans en
télévision la télé ça allait mieux alors
les années voyage moins bien bas
peut-être mais enfin en fait que j'aime
je n'ai pas de problème avec le fait de
recevoir des critiques avec tout ce que
vous mais moi je veux rien faire pour
loana moi je veux qu'elle aille se faire
soigner chez des gens danser mais elle a
déjà fait l a fait plein de séjour à
l'hôpital
c'était mal a des regrets d'avoir laissé
à bipolarité en disant n'importe quoi et
en retraite il ya danger je suis même
s'il ya plein d'artistes qui sont
regardés
kanye west qui sont bipolaires et c'est
ça les empêche pas d'être sur le devant
de la scène et de faire d'autres choses
on va pas l'enfermer à l'hôpital toute
sa bile one a le droit d'avoir des
projets la droite vouloir être dans la
lumière est la droite vous la retourne
la télé elle rêve de refaire de la
télévision mais pas qu à faire des
documentaires mais voilà qu'aujourd'hui
son état ne nous garder enfermés à vie
et le moment absolument pas mais il faut
d'abord la soigner avant qu'elle reparte
sur le surnomma consulter les cannes et
roméo bio ce qui veut dire guillaume
c'est que peut-être c'est un moyen de
aussi de la sortir de là et puis parlons
mais il faut parler aussi concrètement
parce que c'est bien de dire qu'il faut
qu'elle voit des psychologues des
médecins etc
mais dans le concret loana elle n'a plus
d'argent il lui restait ya quelques mois
en milieu où tout le monde même quand on
devient d'arc d'accord pour ce n'est
qu'en mai après pour vivre concrètement
elle va pas rester ad vitam et à la
vitamine temps mais là à l'hôpital
non mais bien sûr ne lui reste plus
d'argent elle est très seul elle a
quelques amis qui sont là pour elle elle
est très seul
donc je
je pense je pense qu'avoir fait quelques
semaines de tournage avec des gens où
elle est retournée sur des lieux qui
l'ont marqué qui lui rappelle de bons
souvenirs d'avoir s'il est là c'est
qu'il a considérés d'avoir échangé parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé avec l hudson
garni qui était en tournage à beaucoup
par lesquels il passé deux heures au
téléphone par jour avec elle de
retrouver une interaction sociale d'être
payés on va pas se mentir on va dire
recevoir une somme d'argent qui lui
permettent de payer son loyer de
s'arranger physiquement et voilà et 16
je vous dis tout ce qu'on a fait de
manière officielle après on a fait
d'autres choses et je veux pas le dire
parce que je suis pas démago mais je
suis obligée d'en de sous-entendre parce
qu on nous attaque là dessus et ça je le
remets on est là pour l'aider loana
voilà oui avant pendant et après le
documentaire et si elle a besoin de quoi
que ce soit je le redis elle peut nous
le demander et moi est on est on est
tous là pour tu deviens 17 pas d'accord
avec elle pour répondre à à géraldine
viret de loana non je suis pas d'accord
avec gerdi parce que loana ne veut pas
se faire soigner sur le long terme ça
c'est un vrai problème c'est à dire que
quand elle est trois semaines à
l'hôpital il faut qu'elle reste plus
longtemps elles 120
elle est majeure adulte responsable
vous ne pouvez pas en france interné
quelqu'un contre son gré et elle est
fâchée avec beaucoup de monde elle les
coud tu peux te conseille et c'est vrai
que quand elle suit un traitement
parfois l'abandonnent elle se replonge
dans des médicaments qu'elle prend elle
même c'est très compliqué de soigner
loana au delà du traitement je pense que
loana nom va se reconstituer un
environnement et un entourage ça c'est
sûr et moi je trouve ça super ce que tu
as fait guillaume parce que quelque part
tu lui as donné des projets nos qu'elle
a pu se projeter elle pensait à autre
chose mais de son esprit sur autre chose
c'est vachement bien